sur le prochain projet de loi est ce que
monsieur collomb sera capable d'écouter
dans le projet de loi qui vient de
passer sur le terrorisme ne l'a pas été
et donc je continue c'est même seul on
peut continuer à vouloir porter la
politique différemment
j'aimerais bien que ce qu'il apportait
différemment il ya six mois la porte
réellement nous écoute pas et donc non
pardon j'ai entendu parfois rarement des
gens de france et insoumise ou des
républicains voir des gens du parti
socialiste dire des choses qui étaient
justes et quand c'est juste c'est juste
mon un chien c'est pas la peine de se
braquer parce que ça vient pas de vos
rangs c'est quand même ce que disait me
semble-t-il emmanuel macron pendant la
campagne présidentielle et c'est mieux
d'appliquer ce qu'on dit après aussi